if I make more than $29,000 a year
will I be paying more in taxes yeah but
the rich still payment well I have to
yes what do you think let me know what
do you think is a single biggest problem
with the current health care system the
United States how do you think it should
be fixed we've talked about this a whole
lot and do you buy the bill of goods
that the official Bernie Sanders
campaign is selling I know we have a lot
of former Bernie supporters
what do you line up single-payer health
care universal health care do you know
the difference which one do you prefer
okay let's go to this video for some
context as to what we'll be talking
about the campaign of Bernie Sanders
they released this video finally
explaining how they will pay or he will
pay for Medicare for lots of problems
but Medicare for all here's their
explanation the truth is we are already
paying for our broken health care system
why are you so shocked by this right now
we spend over three trillion dollars a
year on a crappy broken system right
rapping we pay about twice as much per
person as our friends in Japan and
Germany and for what to have over 30
million people uninsured and over 40
million who can't afford the insurance
they have I think I want my money back
yeah probably shouldn't gone with a
casino clip but although we pay for
better health care that's the most
important quite that's the most that's
the question that I think is most
compared to here so this is something
that's important the premise is people
are uninsured repeated studies have
shown us that sometimes by the way an
increase in total number of uninsured
people it actually just has to do with
people who make above average income
opting to go uninsured while the actual
number of uninsured poor people goes up
sorry I'm in Jersey goes up this is me I
just had a stroke people who can afford
it need some of that health care for
insurance people who are poor actually
more of them are signing up so the
numbers are a little bit more
complicated and they make it seem and
that's just the most commonly cited
number by the way I was one of them I
was one of those people when I was in my
early 20s it was stupid
don't roll that don't roll the dice like
I did but instead I decided to save more
money I didn't pay for health care and
then I got the AIDS alright next clip
let's see how they explain this is their
big justification is that it will
actually cost less that's the crux
we're already projected to spend more
than 50 trillion over the next 10 years
for a system only a big pharma executive
could love a lot of that money comes
from the government but the rest it
comes from you this would change for the
better by moving to a Medicare for All
system that will actually save you and
everyone else in America a whole lot of
money don't take that from me
take it from a conservative study backed
by the Koch brothers who are you levar
burton you don't have to take my word
for it here's a six-year-old who's
barely literate it's an up book I'm
watching your show levar no right wait
I'll offload it onto the migrant working
class so as far as the claiming by the
way there's a coke funded study that
approved that this plan would reduce
costs which of course I don't agree with
but they say over 10 years Washington
Post fact checked it like two years ago
gave it three Pinocchio's that's one
more than two yeah I just want to show
that I know how to drag this yes so
that's a math there you go actually four
out of the five studies conducted have
shown that there is a cost increase for
Sanders plan also important of the
author of that study himself said that
it did not show Bernie Sanders plan
would reduce costs and he kindly
requested that Bernie stop saying that
would study it didn't say that so it
just kindly stop saying it said that
this by the way hit the notification
bell if you're subscribed that doesn't
mean a whole lot hit all notifications
and do consider subscribing to crowd
herb it's another YouTube channel that
hasn't been banned by the overlords yet
so they do give my lawyer
H yeah we're flying under the radar here
by broadcasting it merely to everyone
then they go on to explain this system
in depth let's let's roll it I want to
freeze it for a second let me explain
how ok pause all right tax the wealthy
we already do right they pay a
disproportionate amount of taxes
eliminating paperwork oh really is that
so you'll be effective at eliminating
paperwork federal government
reduce drug costs well they don't really
explain how they're going to reduce drug
cost just let them tell people I would
like you to stop paying so much for
drugs
no okay we tried kindly vote Bernie for
re-election no well I mean you know he's
not I mean let's do the actuary tables
it's gonna be whoever is VP I have no
idea it's very true yeah I'd have every
idea don't be dead let's continue after
that free spring first let's talk taxes
I know more I know tax that's bad but
let's do it what Republicans in the
for-profit health care industry know for
profit understand that we're not talking
about new money we're talking about
money that's currently being taken right
out of your pocket by drug and insurance
companies now all this money the
corporation's tax you tax for example
the cost of an employer health plan for
a family of four is twenty eight
thousand dollars over twelve thousand of
which is paid directly by the employee
through premiums and out-of-pocket costs
in fact if you include health care
premiums the United States is already
one of the highest taxes nations in the
world all that operations tax you tax is
why the health care industry reports
over a hundred billion dollars in
profits last year alone a so much wrong
with this but we all second you mean
that employees have to pay anything for
their health care but employers the evil
monocled employers behind a bed of
pharmaceuticals we'll get to the hundred
billion dollars in profits that's a
really misleading number but under the
definition if this Corporation reaches
in your pocket tax but anytime you pay
for goods or services you're being taxed
by corporations let's talk about it
being said here's sure taxes get passed
on as costs to the consumer someone tell
big grocery big tech app creators and
KitchenAid everyone I'm an oxo man
Cuisinart great stuff
[Laughter]
braving warranties not so generous but
that's why I have my Amex oh there's
there no sponsor don't be pissed so it's
like I've handed here Curtis here do you
see what they say one hundred billion
dollars for the healthcare industry in
profits last year okay this is important
to note because this is the kind of it's
not just as as false as the previous
study that they cite with the man saying
stop citing the exact that what I meant
- huh but this is pretty misleading I
don't want to say dishonest maybe they
don't necessarily know better but what
could what possibly could be misleading
when you are citing a statistic hundred
billion dollars in profit for the entire
healthcare industry can anyone think why
would it it's not a company it's from an
entire industry
okay that's important to note for scale
look at the food industry 137 billion
dollars in food is a human right the
tech industry the top three companies
alone one hundred and thirty billion
dollars in profit well that's now for
scale the biggest insurer health ensure
you knighted health versus let's compare
a company to a company and this is
really important by the way because the
health healthcare industry as a whole is
not what is spearheading innovation it's
not these are not the people who are
creating new products it is companies
within an industry competing against
each other just like Apple invented the
iPhone we don't say if you look at the
profits of the entire smartphone
industry and attribute the profits of
the iPhone no Samsung would love to get
in on that action but your phone has
exploded over over we look at companies
the company the individual company who
wants to be profitable they are going to
create I don't know if the cure for the
polio vaccine it's not everyone pooling
their resources together saying but you
if we all just came in together we can
upload a billion in profits are no
companies want to make their name they
want to make their money back we'll get
into how they do that in a second but
just naming an industry is not an
accurate measurement here so let's
compare apples to apples Apple then made
over fifty nine billion dollars in
annual profits versus UnitedHealth evil
monocles a health insurance company 14
billion that's what we I call
statistically significant and lest you
think that's absurd to say well in there
they can do that with anything Germany
who declared the
Internet a human right by the way
they've now there's now an argument to
be made and actually I think the
government sort of in a backhanded way
has recognized this that people can't
work today without smartphones and so
now you can remember the Obama phone
lady oh right what do you guys love that
that's Obama from reading was an Oracle
prophetic indeed yes go ahead over time
you and your cricket phone so you just
declare knew the right well then there
you go you can simply stop to desert
let's start by subsidizing I don't know
Apple coca-cola let's look at a company
who have they have more significant
profit margins than the health care
industry and by the way the reason
insurance is so expensive is because
there's a lack of competition when you
compare it to other industries not more
single-payer would not help with that
you want to look at industries where you
have skyrocketing costs look at
industries that are the most heavily
regulated you can look at health care
you can look at education and you can
look at I don't know transport health
care education transportation everything
you thrilled with the airline is Fox
here's something that Bernie doesn't
address in the video or the campaign
officially Archer speak he speaks for
Bernie who will actually be taxed under
this proposal now they claim in the
video right that it would only be the
super-rich right okay a little bit of
cold water here if you were to
confiscate the wealth of all
billionaires in the United States in the
entire world know you know isn't the
entire great boiled it wouldn't pay for
three average years of Medicare for all
hang it and if we really wanted a fun
Sanders plan it's estimated again by
economists people who Bernie sometimes
sites and they say stop don't do that
anymore you're lying
stop doing up doing it because you are
misleading and I could hurt you and I'm
an economist it's estimated that we need
to double all personal corporate and
triple I think I think triple payroll
taxes I think we have any out Washington
Examiner in Bloomberg there what's the
payroll task you might be asking why
want to make sure that I read this so
just so you're clear because a lot of
people if you're an employee not
necessarily an employer this might be
somewhat foreign to you correct a
payroll taxes the tax withheld from an
employee salary by an employer who
remits it to the government on their
behalf the tax is based on wages
salaries and tips paid to employees
payroll tax
are deducted directly from the employees
earnings and paid directly to the
Internal Revenue Service the IRS I go by
the funny name here because I want to be
accurate by the employer hold on a
second that sounds like an actual
corporation passing payroll taxes down
to you ever they're talking about this
it's the corporation reaching in your
pocket let me ask a lot of you may not
know hey I actually have payroll taxes
on every last one of you on great would
you ever have that money in your pocket
it's going to Uncle Sam I would love it
one hell of a baby grip their audio wait
I know that you are with child life's
gonna be tough kid if you knew how much
I have to pay just to have you just just
to pay you know what fine okay that's
that's cool I'll pass I'll pass the
costs on to the employees enjoy thanks
Bernie
so who falls under this super rich with
the Bernie plan right here's something
he let it slip oh if you haven't seen
this clip it's anyone making over twenty
nine thousand dollars a year see if you
can spot it is health care free no it is
not so what we do is exempt the first
twenty nine thousand dollars of a
person's income you may question twenty
people I twenty-nine thousand you pay
nothing in taxes above that in a
progressive way with the wealthiest
people in this country paying the
largest percentage okay I understood a
lot of words there that you want me to
hate rich people and if you like
progressiveness I understand that but if
I make more than twenty nine thousand
dollars a year will I be paying more in
touch yeah but the rich still payment
well I have to yes eventually you will
in fact be screwed yes
so just City understand what's a twenty
five thousand there so he was they up
the number that was him cleaning up his
mess be twenty five twenty nine this is
important if you're on board with the
idea that wealthy people should pay more
just because they haven't to employ
people and you hate the millionaire
billionaire or over 29,000 air class
where does
that is taken from the triple payroll
taxes and personal and corporate text
where does it go from a nurse's point
and I'm using all the money going why is
it so expensive
it goes into CEO salary sometimes goes
into magnificent patrons and hospitals
while they're closing down other
community hospitals can you believe no I
can't I cannot believe they're not I
cannot believe that your source there
your reference was a random nurse say
this is one of the biggest most heated
political topics of our generation for
some perspective we go to fete activist
errs from WOD nine of Grand Rapids
Michigan in Schenectady what's your
opinion cities I'm just here for the
coffee and Oreos now let's look at some
of the actual numbers does the money go
right now with private insurance does it
go just to big atriums and CEO salaries
I mean I don't know maybe she's just a
nurse talking they have yet to ask the
most important question here does all of
this result in better care not even
close
listen and this is one thing you can go
back to some of our previous videos I
think I'll link it in an end card here
so you can see it there are two studies
that people use to try and claim these
other countries have better health care
there's the Commonwealth where studied I
think 11 countries in the United States
was 11 on that list versus the UK who
was one there was another one the
internationals saying that had us right
but below Slovenia and above Cuba so I
mean what's the scale here they're
almost entirely subjective polling data
that's what they that's what they
consist of so the United States
objectively leads the world not even
close in access to medical technology
like MRIs you're four times by the way
is likely to die in a UK hospital and in
the United States they have notoriously
long wait times you can go back to
previous videos to look up the
likelihood of you dying from cancers to
terminal diseases compare the United
States versus other countries objective
parameters objective litmus tests that
you can use not do you like your health
care well I guess it's kind of free so
I'll live on the crap hole that is
Canada and I'm from there but a lot of
money by the way the reason it's so
expensive and it benefits the entire
world's that a lot of this money is also
reinvested into developing new drugs and
medical technologies which brings us to
our next
that Bernie doesn't care about Americans
pay more for prescription drugs than
anywhere else in the world why Big
Pharma we're getting ripped off by the
drug companies that was many of these
drugs we develop using a government
research and grants yet are turned
around and sold at sky-high prices to
those who desperately need life-saving
medication doing drugs we're gonna stop
this outrage in my scouting and cuts the
costs of prescription drugs for patients
and hospitals by more than half
okay at gunpoint
understood so it's fixing doesn't work
it wouldn't help thing right okay and
this goes back again to the previous
point we made about the the profits
what's the industry a huge chunk of that
money goes into medical research
specifically drugs something else to
keep in mind that drug prices soared
under Barack Obama and with the
Affordable Care Act commonly referred to
as Obamacare I refer to it as a portable
Care Act just like I refer to as the
International Internal Revenue Service
useful you're close to the nominee [ __ ]
we Goering this thing I am going to make
sure that I use all of the Sulabh TLAs
links the link though again left us they
love to film at the drug prices
continued right no actually if you take
the price inflation into account this is
one of the most controversial statements
and president Trump State of the Union
address because it was accurate taking
into account the price of inflation
we've seen historic reductions and drug
prices under President Donald Trump okay
doesn't mean that it's perfect yet but
you do see that happening in fixing
prices is something a lot of people
understand when they talk about price
gouging they complain about price
gouging okay if you were to fix prices
let's say Hurricane Katrina people
complain about this there's an emergency
so people are price gouging what does
that mean a convenience store owner
understands if there's scarcity and so
all of a sudden batteries I don't know
how much it is for a pack of double A
batteries what is it a few bucks
depending lithium to keep bunny and
Duracell I don't know it's all big
battery I don't trust him but the point
is between store owner of the bodega
says well now that's not three bucks
that's going to be $30 yet people say
well that's that's price gouging well
you know what happens if that person
doesn't charge more in that instance
someone walks in and goes hey I can with
all these batteries that are only three
bucks org that's what happens
and then you treat more regulations as
well actually we're going to guarantee
that the price does not go up regardless
of scarcity regardless of supplying a
man but we are now going to be limited
to two per customer and then you have
someone sending all their family and
then they go they they've now that all
of a sudden they're hoarding even more
batteries and they start selling on the
street you create a black market that
anytime you try to fix a bureaucratic
problem with more bureaucracy I don't
wanna say any time but most of the time
it doesn't worry that well so going back
to the drugs that have reduced in cost
after Donald Trump why do drugs cost so
much - we've talked about medical
research let me put a finer point on it
the average cost right now to develop a
single new drug is 2.6 billion dollars
oh that's now that sounds pretty bad to
be then take into account that the
approval rate for drugs entering
clinical development is less than 12% so
what requires the big evil monocled
billionaires that they have to invest
Wow and there has to be some chance of
recouping in the investment who would
spend billions of dollars with a 12%
chance of a drug being approved by the
way the money that goes into research
that's the reason why the United States
you guessed it leaves the world in the
creation of new drugs and medical
research papers it's not even close I
like leading they talked about this in
the video Germany doesn't spend as much
on health care really Germany doesn't
well I'm guessing that it's for very
much the same reason that Canada doesn't
spend that much on the military you're
welcome raising montreal it's not that
hard to figure out I could run for
present but I don't want to all right
next clip you don't even want to know
how much the United States wastes on
processing paper will you tell us it
adds up to hundreds of billions of
dollars of paperwork and billing with
one single payer oh that is not where
the money should go on paper Blissett
estimates show ever all could save more
than half a trillion dollars each and
every year on administrative costs okay
this is truth so this is a very true
claim private insurance with the insane
regulations and government red tape that
we've talked about they have a lot of
administrative expenses absolutely that
is true but the estimates
the Sanders campaign they use their
completely inaccurate why because you'd
be expanding Medicare to everyone to
compare administrative expenses for
Medicare currently as it exists right
it's only for 65 and older patients who
are over 65 they spend far more overall
on health care so the administrative
costs will of course be a much smaller
percentage also something else that's
important to note the administrative
spending can actually lower all kinds of
other costs and spendings within a
health care a health insurance company
it's just like here we have to spend a
whole lot and updating the studio making
sure that the insulation is not
flammable making sure that we don't have
rats chewing on the wires in the attic
making sure that we have equipment here
that can cost many hundreds of thousands
of dollars annually that doesn't go
directly into the pockets of employees
because it allows us to work more
efficiently more effectively and employ
more people in the long run so to look
at it through this just this myopic it's
just it makes it makes me very sad but
also angry oh I'm really angry because
then I realize I'm sad when I think of
how much a company has to spend an
administrative costs and then I'm angry
when I realize that the proposed
solution to less paperwork is the
federal government just consider that
just consider the number of pages for
government bills ever the Affordable
Care Act was overt it was 10,000 pages
and according to Washington folks just
one cut see that's not too long because
frankly this is to be expected in any
large and complex governmental
undertaking yeah taking over a fifth of
the American economy could be considered
sizable by the way we're also talking
about what we're talking about big evil
corporations I understand the problem
with transparency I believe that the
government should absolutely ensure that
companies corporations don't lie to
people they don't lie what's on there or
they don't lie on the label they don't
lie to people as far as their business
practices I'm I'm supportive a trip of
transparency just like I'm supportive of
the military because I believe that's a
legitimate role of government yes that
falls under the purview of government to
make sure that consumers are not being
lied to when they make their decisions
while we're talking about transparency
hey we signed a health care bill that
took over a fifth of the economy that
admittedly from Nancy Pelosi they had to
to know what was in it compare that to
the liability that a company faces the
reason they have to pay so much on
administrative costs it's because they
don't get to I don't know where am I
going and I cover I don't know about
your copay I'm gonna side and see what
happens let me put this insulin needle
in your lower abdomen and hope for the
best
they don't get to do it for context when
people talk about big evil corrupt
corporations and I agree there are some
absolutely of course I'm not saying that
all of them are angels but what I do
leftist why do progressives why does
Bernie assume that everyone in the
government is inherently altruistic for
context Bernie Sanders of Vermont
senator Bernie Sanders of Burlington
Vermont is less beholden to insider
trading laws than Jeff Bezos it doesn't
apply here and this is this is important
to go back to Bernie you get a whole
video on here about how you pay for a
thirty four trillion dollar a decade
plan without explaining any real way
that he would come up with this money is
it's because we know the answer would be
taxing everyone sorry only if you make
over twenty nine thousand dollars a year
I know that's a really full struggling
middle class that's why Donald Trump's a
prick but everyone making over twenty
nine thousand dollars a year in their
households they would have to be taxed
at significantly higher rates and here's
if we have to look at a comparison
because these numbers don't exist in a
vacuum look at how things went under
Barack Obama premiums went up
deductibles went up drug prices went up
and with Donald Trump he hasn't gotten a
whole lot done I will admit that but at
least we've seen prices go down when you
account for inflation but I have to go
back before we end this we're talking
about can't this bothers me so much
people talk about the world and they
talk about all how much less they pay in
health care really places like Iceland
Denmark Sweden yeah you can because of
the Allies you can't because we decided
we were fed up when a couple of guys
decided to take out some boats yeah then
we shut up and said all right I have to
come back there nice Canada is a great
example he will run raised my entire
life oh we don't have to pay this much
for our drugs yeah you're welcome you're
not the ones creating the drugs and the
medical technology from which the entire
world
benefits you want to know how you can
actually gauge the United States
benefits everybody in the world
unlike empires to have come before this
idea that the United States is an evil
empire okay
imagine any other empire in the history
of mankind okay take a pic what about
the Greeks you want to go the Romans you
want to go with the Ottomans okay let's
go with Rome picture Rome only instead
of a little place well you're talking
about in in Rome
what gave Rome being the land mass of
the United States okay not to mention
the military the purchasing power the
GDP and Rome for some odd reason has the
second largest country as far as land
mass to the north of it outside of China
but our I think it's at least close the
lowest population per capita some of the
highest concentration of rich vast
natural resources with no way to defend
it and Rome says oh you know what we're
doing we're gonna engage in free trade
with them and let them benefit from our
modern medical innovation we're gonna
give Canada plumbing I don't kinda
medicine they had but I think they had
plumbing and I was pretty cool back then
so the point is it's never happened
before yeah you guys don't have to pay
for your military because we foot the
bill you can look at NATO we did a video
on that but if you want to brag about
how low your health care costs are
because your government decides to
subsidize American medical innovation
well this is just my opinion I think we
should shut that tap off and see how you
like it
and Kenneth you know what you're gonna
have to start buying some more tugboats
and propeller planes because you no
longer have the luxury of being
protected by our Marines by our Navy and
our Air Force so we're not giving you
any more penicillin piss off enjoyed
this video subscribe or hit the
notification bell because that lets your
mobile device do people still say cell I
don't think they say but no one says LTE
we should say cellular but we don't say
LTE but then what was there was there
was roaming do we still have roaming I
think we still have roaming if you're
watching this on mobile I've wasted a
ton of your in you're likely driving
you're probably dead
everybody's looking back now and the
road is just there are some lights and
sirens going off maybe there's like a
pair of slacks in your the grille of
your car
next to the Rudolph nose that you put in
for some holiday festivity only now it's
covered in someone else's blood so hit
the notification bell join Mudd Club it
lied with credit calm slash mug club
because that's how we support this we
don't actually make any money off of
youtube and we do a full dailies like
80% more content and you know what I
hope that your blood type is o-negative